釈尊と鍛冶屋さんの対話
曖昧な信仰より幸福を確保する具体的な方法
仏教はそういう風に 仏教でも儀式がないというわけじゃないんです
儀式 祭り いくらでもありますけど
本来の仏教にはもう一つもないんです
だから人間と儀式は切り離れ離せないだけの話です
じゃあ経典はただそのまま読んでみましょう
阿比山だけプッタスッタンというちょっと長い名前の経典で
アシバンデカ このアシっていうのは剣のことですね
バンドカっていうのは結ぶという意味なんですけど
この金属を合成して剣を作る職人という意味だと思います
だからまあ鍛冶屋さんと言っても間違いはないんだけど
でもやっぱり剣の専門職人ですね
刀鍛冶 刀鍛冶 ですね だからそれと特別な儀式
技術ですよ 普通の包丁とかあれこれ刃物を作ることと
剣は随分違いますからね
場所っていうのはナーランダという町で
バーバーリカというマンゴーの林で
この経典対話が起きたんです
質問する人は鍛冶 鍛冶屋を営んでいる村長ですね
で 村長の質問は 諸氏 西地方のバラモンたちは手に水紅をでしたっけ？水瓶を持っている
カーマンデルーカ これで一つの儀式なんですね
ヌルヌルする鶴の首輪をかけているという
首に花輪かけてますけど
なんか気持ち悪がっていって
あれじゃないんだ みんなヌルヌルしたものかけてるんだよとか
いつでも水が水瓶を持ってるんだよとかね
だからイメージしてください
いろんな絵に何かある
このバラモン人の森林たちの絵とかね
首になんかかけて手で水瓶を持っているとかね
これ西地方っていうのは
これはちょっと東寄りだからね
お釈迦様の方は 西っていうのはこのまあカシミールとかね
まあ今現代パキスタン地方とかそこら辺でしたから
まあなんかちょっと知らないから
だからちょっと気持ち悪がって言ってるんです
まあおそらくはまあスイレン蓮華などの花輪の首飾りでしょうと思いますけどね
そんなに悪口は言わなくても
セーワラマーリカっていうのはパーリ語の単語なんですね
沐浴の儀式を行う ウダカローハカ
朝晩沐浴することで心の罪を流すんですね
この沐浴儀式っていうのは
このガンジス川に飛び込んで
もうそれでもう心を魂を浄化するんです
まあ儀式で言うだけ体は綺麗になるかもしれませんだけど
どうやって そういう人々は真面目に沐浴することで自分の心に罪がないんだとえらい勘違いしているんです
だからあまり実際人のお金を奪うことやらね
人を騙すことやら 人の弱みを握って金儲けることやら
あんまり気にしないんです
だから本当はバラモン人の存在っていうのは
今もそうなんです あれは迷惑なんです
とにかくしょうがない
で たまたまそれに反応して真面目にやってる人もいますし
それでこの なんでそんなに堂々と悪いことを道徳も気にしないで生きているのかというと
だって我々は罪に汚れませんよと
確実に朝も晩も沐浴して清めているんだからと
護摩を焚いていると 護摩供養をやっているんですね
このバラモンたちが 聖なる火にお供えをして
呪文を唱えて 神とコミュニケーションを取る儀式なんですね
だから火を焚いて そこでいろんなお供えをして供養して
それで呪文を唱える そうすると
このバラモン人と神がコミュニケーションを取るというふうに言ってはくれます
信仰をして 今も結婚式はインドのね
まあ火を三回ぐらい回されて
結婚式っていうのは火は神様なんですね
決して結婚はそれぐらい危ないことをやる
できればやるなよという意味じゃないんです
神様を礼をして結婚式という
火は地上にいる神の代表ですね
西洋的な言葉で言えば天使なんですね
彼らが死者を呼んだり
死者に報告をしたり 天に行かされたり
行かされたりする だから死者儀礼もやってます
人が死んだらまたすごい供養をやってもうもう名前で呼んで
まあだからこの功徳でもうどうぞ天国に行ってくださいとかなんとか言うんです
そこはまず西地方のバラモン人たちのことを言って
だから西地方の人々は本格的にバラモン宗教の儀式なり守っていたんです
お釈迦様のいた地方のバラモンたちは
まあどちらかでどちらでもいいやということでいたんだから
有名なバラモンではほとんど仏教徒になってしまったんです
大阿羅漢であり 学者である釈尊なら
すべての生命が死後天国に行けるようにしてあげることはできるのではないでしょうかと
お釈迦様に聞くんです
この人から見れば あんなだらしない
品格のない もう性格の悪いあの連中は
死者を天国に行かせるって何言ってるんでしょうかと
それだったら偉大なるお釈迦様だったらすべての生命を天国に行かせることできるでしょうという質問なんです
コメントは釈尊がなぜ一切衆生の救い主だと明言しないのかと思っていたと思います
お釈迦様は私は大乗仏教で言っているように
一切衆生が成仏するために自分が鐘を鳴らしているとか
そうあまり言わないんですね
そんな大胆 お釈迦様は大胆でしたけど
もう鐘鳴らして鳴らしただけで
すべての生命が成仏できるとか
そこまでは言わないんです
それでお釈迦様が常識に訴えるですね
できることなら自分の考えを相手に押し付けないようないのはブッダの指導方法の一つです
お釈迦様の説法を学ぶと
ものすごくこの教育ってどういうものかと
世界一流の教育方法を学ぶことができるんですよ
それをお釈迦様自分でも言うんです
自分が偉大なる師であると
教えることなら もう生命の中で誰もいません
自分ほど能力ある人は
そういうわけで この教育学的に経典を学んでみると
このお釈迦様はどうやってこのいろんな人にいろんなものを教えるのかと
その方法っていうのは素晴らしいんですよ
だからこの 混乱することもなく
反対する人々を作ることもなく
敵を作ることもなく 暗殺される恐れもなく
ものすごい見事に この大胆な革命的な教えを世に広げてしまったんです
ということは 例えば儀式
儀礼に対して仏教はものすごい考え方を持ってますけど
そんなのは堂々と言っちゃうと
世界人類がもう仏教を壊す
潰すんですよ でもそういうことをなく
すごくうまく話を持っていくんです
その方法ですね だからこの場合は
お釈迦様が取った態度はどういうことかと
相手が宗教のことを精神のことをよく知らない一般人であるならば
常識に訴える方法を取るんです
これ一つの方法なんです
常識に話してみると 常識ですから反対することはできません
他の答えがないという意味ではありません
例えば なぜお釈迦様が一切それほど能力あるあるんだから
なぜ一切修行を積まないのかというと
答えがちゃんとありますよ
いろんなところで答えあるんですよ
お坊さんたちに言った答えとかね
それは結構難しいんです
この人にはそんなことは言ってないんで
業の話とか因果法則とかね
そんなのは全然言ってないんです
しかし 正しく答えるんです
村長さん ではあなたに伺います
自分が思う通りに答え答えしなさいと
これにわしは丁寧にタンゲウェッタパティプッチッサーミヤターテカメヤタターナムビャーカレイヤーシティ
あなた思う通りに答えてくださいと
これコメント 優れた師は相手に質問をする
だいたい先生がとても優れている場合は
一方的に教えることはしないんです
みんなにいろいろ質問先に聞いてみるんです
それで良いところを見せようとしないで
素直に思った通りに答えれば
弟子の知識能力が向上するんです
だから私もたまたまやってはみるんですけど
これかっこつけていいとこ見せてやろうではないかと思っちゃうんですね
それではダメなんですね
だから無知なまんまで終わっちゃう
いくら喋っても だからこの私は偉大なる弟子じゃないんだから
師弟じゃないんだからうまくいかないんですけど
やっぱりそれでも質問したら相手に答えられるもの
相手の常識からデータ取ろうとする
それ 心理学的なシステムがあるんで
その裏で相手が考えている
相手が考えているんだから
そこは整理するだけでないと聞いてくれないんですよ
時々 今私はあまり外へ出ませんだから時間なくて
前はよくよくあっちこっち行ったり来たりしたんです
その時突然誰かが来て
あんたインド人？と聞くんですよ 8
割違いますよと言ったっても
あまり言って意味がないとわかったんです
それであ そうか やっぱりインド人だ
だから自分の答え耳入ってないんです
それ何回経験があって
私は あんたネパール？そうです
あんたバングラデシュ？そうですけど
そのままはいと言うんです
あ そうか やっぱり俺がよく物事を知ってるんだということで
もう帰る だから最初からもう俺が知ってるんだぞということであって
この人が何者かと知りたいという気持ちはもうとうないんです
だから私は衣を着ているのを見て
夏 あ 夏はこの服はすごくいいですね
涼しくてとかね 冬も同じ形で着てる
あーいいですね これで暖かくてとか言ったりする
まあ違いますけどね もう勝手ですよ
ある日信号を待っていると
ものすごい冬でしたけど
でも私は全然寒くも何も感じてなかったし
ものすごい服いっぱい着ていた人が来て
もう震えているんですね
本当にすごく寒いですね
この服では大丈夫でしょう
やっぱりそうですよ 寒くて
まあしょうがないって言って
本人ものすごく喜んじゃったんです
だからこの時々取材されちゃって
私もね たまにですけどね
みんなもう 23年ぐらい見ますからね
あんた日本でびっくりしたことが何かあるのかと
今更言えないしね 言いたいことを言っても理解しないんですよ
例えば日本人に質問されたら
外人ならはいそうですと答えなさいと
そうでなきゃ大変なことになるんだよと
これ言える それなんで？って言ったら
だって日本人が人の話を聞かないんだよ
そういう私が発見してるものたくさんありますけど
一つも公では言えるものじゃないんです
だから今もやっぱりそれで本当に困っているんですけど
だって瞑想を教えられませんからね
いくら言っても自分がやりやり方でやってるんです
そこでお釈迦様からあんた勝手に答えてくださいと
好きなように質問をするのです
あなた知ってることで答えなさいということは
その人の知識で答えなさい
その人の心がオープンになっているんですよ
対話状態になっているんです
自分の意見を言ってるんだからね
その窓を開けてくれたんだから
そちらに新しいデータを入れることはできるんです
だから 先生がなんで質問するのかというと
決して頭がいいか悪いか調べるためじゃないんです
ただ 心の窓を開けて開けなさいよと
鍵は裏から開けないと
窓の鍵っていうのは外から開けられるものありますか？玄関だったら外から開けられますけど
窓っていうのはやっぱり私は見たことないんですよ
外から開けられる鍵 だから心のっていうのは
心には玄関ないんだから窓はあるんです
心は自分だけのことだから
自分が心から出て行きませんだから玄関はないんです
窓はあるんです 外のことを知りたいと
これが鍵かけていると
外が外は何が起こるのかわからないでしょうに
だからちゃんと教育システムを知っている先生は質問するんです
質問すると答えなくちゃいけないんです
で 答えると何のことなく本人が窓を開けてるんです
中にあるものを外へ出すために
出ないと出せませんだからね
それで新しいデータのやりとりはできるんです
ここで人がいる 彼は殺生する
盗む 邪淫をする 噂 嘘 噂
粗悪語 無駄話を語る 異常な欲と異常な怒りがある
邪見者である
パナディパーティーアディーナダーイカーミスミッチャーチャーリムサーワーディピスナーワーチョパーサワーチョサンパッパラッピアビジャールビャーパンナチットミッチャーディッティポとい
う十悪のリストですね
そこでお釈迦様は言うのは
ある人がいて その人はこの十悪をやってるんだと
だから十悪全部でなくても一つ二つでもどちらでもいいんです
じゃあリスト全部言うんです
たくさんの人々が集まって大集合会を開き
祈りをする 呪文を唱える
合唱して念じる この人は死後天界に生まれますようにと
だからすごいからかってます
ですから この私はちょっとあまり訳できませんだからいい加減な適当な訳したんですけど
ヒンドゥー教の人々がやってるその同じ単語を使っているんです
このこの人が死んだったら大集合会やるんです
親戚やらみんな集まる
それであらゆるもう一人一人が念珠を持っていろいろ唱えているわ
もう合唱して舞台登場しながらいろんなお祈りするわ
いろんなこと だからみんな何を祈願する祈願するかというと
この人がどうか天国に行けますようにと
大衆の祈り呪文を唱え
合唱して念じた という理由でその人は昇天すると思いますか？誰かさんが祈りしてるんだだから
あの悪人が天国に行くとあんた思いますか？違いますと村長が返事する
ものすごい悪いことする人が
みんなあのどうか天国に来ますようにって言ったら
天国に行くんだったらもう話にならんだからね
これお釈迦様 たとえ話持ってくるんです
村長さん 人々は大きな石を深い水に投げ捨てる
それから皆大石を浮いてくれたまえ
陸上に上がってくれたまえと祈る
讃嘆する お願で念じる
でっかい石をもうすごい深い水に投げ捨てて
大石を浮いてくれたまえと一生懸命お祈りすると
では 大衆の祈りの力で念力で大石が
浮くと思われますか？あんた思いますかね
その石がどんどん浮いてくると
違いますと村長が返事する
で 結論 そのように村長さん
失笑する思うんですね
邪見者に対して たとえ大衆が
天界や天界 天界に生まれますようにと祈ったり
合掌して念じたりしても
その人は死後 不幸な境地に地獄に陥るのです
明確にわかるでお釈迦様へのくらい祈ったっても
石が浮いてくれないんだよと
そのように悪行する人がどんな儀式儀礼やったっても
話にならんよと できるわけないんだと
コメントもし神が祈りが実るようにしたならば
それはまあ概念はいいですよ
人の話を聞いて特別扱いでしょ
それって悪いでしょ それだったら我々は平気でいくら僧侶かってね
誰かにお金でも払ってね
私は死んじゃったらお前ら来たら祈ってくれよと
あるいは遺言書いて 私のことを朝晩 1 年間ぶっ続けて祈りする者に
私の財産を全部あげると言って
弁護士に頼んでおいておけば
もし 1 日でもやらなかったらもうダメだ
言えばやってくれますよ
金が欲しいんだから みんな
それで天国に行くならばね
で でお釈迦様 2番目の答え
ここで人がいる 彼は不殺生
不邪淫 嘘をつかず 二枚舌にならず
粗悪語無駄話語語らす
異常な欲も怒りもなく正見である
大衆が大集会を開き 祈ったり
呪文を唱えたり 合掌して念じたりする
この人は死後 不幸に地獄に陥りますようにと
大体良いこと 人にとっては誰も祈ってくれませんだからね
大衆の祈りの力 呪文の力
合掌して念じる力によって
その人をお棺 死後ですよ
これなんか 今日はヨガの番組を見たせいなんです
死後不幸に地獄に陥れることができると思いますかと
みんなにできますかと
その良いことした人は地獄に落とすことは
そう思いませんと村長が返事をする
返事をする たとえバターか油がいっぱい詰まっている瓶がある
甕ですかな それを底が深い水に投げ捨てて
石などでその瓶を割る
瓶ってあの水瓶と同じ大きいものですよ
えーと 投げた小石やこの瓶の破片
などですね これ野じゃなくてね
などが下へ沈む あの入れ物は普通土で作っているね
そちらにインドは昔はね
まあ昔の時代だったら素焼きの入れ物ですよ
そちらにもバター入れるんですよ
このバターといっても
あの皆様が知ってるバターよりはすごく軽いんです
このギーというものなんです
ギーっていうのは このバターを作ることと違うやり方で作るんです
これはほとんど脂肪分ですね
牛乳の脂だけ ちょっと温めて上のところを取って
もうちょっと温めてというと
なんかまあほとんど油みたいで
バターよりはちょっとあんまり美味しくはないんですけどね
で まあだからすごく軽いんです
バターよりはものすごい軽いんです
まあ油 ほとんど油ですね
牛乳の だからそういうものはどんどんしまった
この 器をね 水につけて
それから石とか何とか投げて割る
割ると投げた石とか この
釜の破片とかはまあ下へ沈むでしょうし
バターか油が水の上に浮く
人は大集合会を開き 祈る
呪文を唱える 合掌して念じるんです
それでバターは下へ行けと下へ沈むと
これパーリ語で本当に祈るする
その単語で言って まあバターさまよとどうか
では村長さん 大衆の祈りの力でそのバターがか油が下へ沈むと思いますか？いいえ
そう思いませんと村長が返事をする
このように不世出の聖賢者が
たとえ大衆が地獄に落ちろと祈っても
死後天界に生まれるんだよ
ということで もうまるっきり祈りなんかはもうきれいさっぱり捨てているんです
バカバカらしくて笑っちゃいますよということなんです
だから本当に原文で読めるならば笑えるんですよ
すっごく面白おかしく
というか このもうすごくもう相手の宗教で使う単語を全部大事に使っているんです
村長がブッダの答えに賛同する
それで経典が終わるんです
あ なるほど それで村長の質問がなんでお釈迦様が一切衆生を救わないのかと
返事ありますかね それがギャーギャーと説明するとわかりにくくてね
この鍛冶屋さんにはね
別に知識人 すごい知識人というわけでもないしね
だから本人に考えさせたんです
なるほど 自分がやったことから離れないんだ
自分でやらなくちゃあかんだという答えですよ
だから ああ なるほど お釈迦様は一切衆生を救わないって
こんなのは変だな 変だなとわかるんですよ
だからちゃんと質問に答えがあるんです
うん あの ちょっと解説しています
で 解説もそんなに難しくないんですよ
隣人の貯金口座は自分の投資金になるでしょうかということで
そうなると思ってますよ
祈りする人々は 人の運命
絶対的な存在 神 仏などですね
の勝手で人の運命が定めていると信じることもあるんですね
それが本当であるならば
私たちは何をしても効き目はありません
神様がすべて定めていると
絶対神は絶対なりやと
全知全能なりやと信じちゃうと祈りする必要はないんです
もう意味がない もうとっくに決めてますから
プリインストールですよ
機械 コンピューター買うともうプログラムインストールしてるんだからね
もうどうにもならん 神のしもべになるもの
悪魔に誘惑されるものもされるもの
天界に行くもの 地獄に落ちるもの
すべてもうとっくに定めているんです
祈りは完全無効です だから
いかに矛盾かと 真面目に神様を信仰するならば
絶対やってはいけないことは祈ることなんです
これは神の全知全能であることは冒涜しているんです
だってそれプログラム改造してるんだからね
それは不正ですよ 決してマイクロソフトの VISTA とかね
これは不正にいじれません
いじられませんよ このコードは開放してないんだからね
オープンソースじゃないんです
だからそのまま使うしかないんです
そこで WINDOWS 使うと
大体ウイルスは流行るわ
不正アクセスするわ もう私には毎日 200
300ぐらいスパムメール来るわ
どうにもならんです まあビル・ゲイツ偉大なる神様がそう自分だけ儲かるように作っているんだから
まあソースコードをみんなに教えたら
みんな専門家がたくさん世の中にいるんだから
もうこのいろんな隙間を閉めてくれますよ
閉めてくれて これこれ直したければ
このプログラム使ってくださいと
10ドルぐらいくださいと
そんな大したマイクロソフト以外はソフトウェアそんなに高くないんです
それで邪魔しているんです
みんな儲かることに しかし
あのコードは逆エンジニアリングすると犯罪なんです
我々は会社でいろんな店で買うソフトウェアとか
もう逆エンジニアリングってリバースエンジニアリングって英語で言うんですけど
リバースエンジニアリングしちゃうと犯罪なんです
コピー罪も犯罪ですからね
ですから 神様もそんな感じで
人間の運命は世紀末まで全部決まってるんです
そこを祈りして なんとかもうちょっとそこら辺でなんとかというのは
神の全知全能であることをね
ケチを付けることですよ
だから まあ祈りする人々は
いくら神の立場から見ても天国には行けないんですね
だって神を冒涜することが一番重い罪だから
祈って人の運命を変えられると思うなら
その人は他人の命を自分に操られると思っているんです
祈って 例えば死にかけている人のために祈って祈って
もう病気治ったら その人の運命を自分で操っているでしょう
神のつもりになってるんですね
例えば絶対的宗教と違って
我々みんなで一緒に祈って
この人の病気を治してあげましょうとかね
あるいはこの人を早く死ぬようにしましょうとかね
祈るならば この人々は何をやっているんですかね
神になったつもりですよ
人の運命は自分で操られるとよく思っている
それなら他人にも同じ力がある
でも失敗ですよ あるグループに祈って
人の運命を操れる能力があるならば
他の人々にも同じ能力があるんですよ
そうなってくると この世の中成り立たなくなりますよ
例えば 私は 10人ぐらい人を集めてくれて
私は金持ちになるようにしてくださいというと
20人ぐらい別のところで集めて
あいつはどんどん貧乏になりますようにと祈りしちゃうとどうなるんですかね
世界中人間で同じ意見じゃないんだから
ある家のお母さんが自分の子供が子供の病気が早く治りますようにと祈りすると
隣の奥さんがその奥さんのことを嫌で嫌で嫉妬しているんですね
そうするとコソコソとあの子は亡くなりますようにと祈っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
あの あのお母さんがひどい目に遭いますようにと
祈り聞くことになったらそんなことになりますよ
幸い祈りは効き目がないんだから
幸い平和でいるんです
他の他人に自分を地獄に陥れることができるとすると
危険ではないんですかね
おっかないんですよ 誰かに祈り
祈る 誰かが祈りして自分を地獄に陥れることできるならば
もう危なくて 祈りは偉大なる力にお願いすることで
祈りの一種は偉大なる力があって
そちらにお願いする このような祈りをすればするほど
自分が惨めになる 例えば偉大なる力を信仰して
どうかお願いします どうかお願いします
商売繁盛しますように
子供が病気にならんように
家族がなんとかなりますようにとかね
祈りをする自分は惨めでしょうに
自分が弱気になるんです
自分で頑張ることをどんどん忘れてしまう
朝から晩まで祈りをすることになっちゃうんです
あのこの信仰宗教グループではよくありましたんですね
もう子供とか そのグループの人々のね
病気になると一生懸命真面目に祈る
それで見事にその子供たちは死ぬ
単純な病気ですよ もうもうちょっと風邪がこじれるとかね
アメリカでもね ほんま単純な病気で
このいろいろ信仰宗教のグループが
この神は完璧であると
不完全なものは作りませんと
ですから 病気になったら決して薬あげてはいけませんと
薬あげることは神を冒涜することであると
ですから 我々一斉にお祈りしましょうと言って
子供に何の治療もしないで
祈る それで見事にたくさん死ぬ
あのテレビで皆さん見た
アメリカでどこか地方で
この警察の人々がお墓に連れて行ったんで
お墓でいっぱい子供たちの墓石があるんですよ
名前書いて もう 8歳とか 10歳とか 9 6歳とかね
3歳とか 警察が行ったら
この人々はね ちょっともう 2日 3日で薬で治る病気ですよ
しかし 薬をあげなくて
まあみんな死んじゃったと
そうするとアメリカの法律で子供の面倒を見てない場合は
子供の権利をね なくなるでしょうね
なんでそうしないのか
それはできないんだと
別にその親が子供のこと嫌いとか
そういうことはないんだと
これ宗教だから 信仰だから
法律ではどうすることもできないんだと
だから わずかでも何か法律を
国の法律をもう破るまで待ってるんだと
破ったとこ その言い訳にして
徹底的に調べて壊してやると
だから警察はもう待ってるんですよ
この子供たちをなんとかして救ってあげたいと
だからこの 祈りすると弱気になるんですね
こんな教会 どうな神社に行く暇がない
病院に行きましょうとかね
うん 人が病気になって
今日は今お勤めの時間時間だから
あんた心臓発作起こったって
ちょっと待ってくださいと
私はお勤め終わってからあなた病院に連れて行くぞとかね
あまりにも信仰深くなくなるとそうなるんです
それで人が死ぬんです
だから変ですよ それが
やっぱり自分が まあ仏教的に言いますと
自分が御勤めをする時間であっても
人が病気になると まあお勤めもお釈迦様はあっち行けということで
人を病院に連れて行かなくちゃいけないんです
自分が例えば 15 年間 1 日も欠かさず
ちゃんと朝晩お勤めをやったり
お釈迦様のお供えをやったりしたっても
誰かが突然病気になると
あの 10 年間  15 年間の習慣はそのままきちっと切って
その人の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですよ
だからそれって常識でしょうに
だからこのしきたり宗教になってくると
まあ例えば女性立ち入り禁止というえらい聖なる場所とかあったりするでしょう
例えば突然そちらの女性がすごく病気になっても
ちょっとプライバシーにちょっと寝かせてもらわなくちゃいけないとか
そんないくらこの千年
千五百年も女性が入ったことがないと言ったって
もうそこで寝かせちゃえばいいんですよ
それが常識ということなんです
だからこの あまりにも祈りすると弱気になるんです
必ず祈りは聞いてくれると迷信するならば
狂暴頑固になっちゃうんですね
狂信になる 祈り祈ったら聞いてくれるんだぞと思ったら
もう何でももう調子に乗っちゃって
祈りすぎて 神様は今日のことをうまくいきますようにと
あ 祈ったんだから大丈夫だと
神様が見守っているんだと思っちゃうと
自分で気をつけないんですね
例えばテロリストはなんで自爆テロをやっているんですかね
神のせいでしょう それってすごい迷惑でしょう
人類にとっては だからこの良い結果にはならないんです
自分の心に言い聞かせる祈りなら
心理的な働きが起こるんです
しかし 偉大なる神に祈るのではなくて
そちら辺にある神社仏閣に祈るのではなくて
ただ自分の心に言い聞かせるという祈りがあるんですよ
そちらには心理学的な効き目がちゃんとあるんです
優柔不断がなくなり 頑張る気持ちになることは可能です
だから 自分自身にの心に言い聞かせてあげる祈りなら
心理学的にもうちゃんと効き目があるんです
しっかりすることはできます
しかし それは他人に頼ることではなく
自分自身で自分の幸福を築く人の自己応援なのです
これが自己応援なんです
だって人っていうのはもう気が弱いし
もう自信がないし ですから
自分の心に訴えてあげるんです
しっかりできますようにと
うまくいきますように
その祈りは効きます ある程度に
これも正しく もう決まり
正しく祈ることができればしっかり効きます
それは全然迷信じゃないんです
心理学です それで その効く祈りが誰にできるかというと
自分で頑張りたい 自分の幸福を自分で築きますよますよという思う人にしかできません
だから悪いんだけど 祈りは神を信じていない人に効きます
神はまるっきり信じてない人なら祈りは効きます
信じるならば効いてくれません
なぜならば 祈りには一応心理学的なプロセスがあります
仏教も誓願することは認めるんです
だからその祈りは仏教でもないわけじゃないんです
誓願するという 自分でしっかり決める
例えば 私はお釈迦様に教えられた通りに修行する
だから確実に悟りに達してやると
すべての目的を辞めて解脱するという目的にするんだよ
と それで決めておく 決めておくと
何のことなくその道で進んでいきます
その場合は 自分の祈願は叶います
じゃあ お墓を買っておくことを考えてみましょう
親族 家族が頼りにならないと思う人は
先に自分のお墓を買っておいて
永代供養の費用も払っておく場合がありますね
最近よくあるんです で
昔の人々より自分が進んでいると思ってるんです
昔はあんまり 亡くなっ
おばあさん おじいさんたちはね
私のお墓はどうしようかと全然考えてもないんです
当然死にますからね それで子供たちが
孫たちがちゃんとお墓を作って
ちゃんとお寺に行ってお布施を納めて法事をやってもらうんです
現代になってくると カッタソク制度になっちゃって
親は子供を信頼しないし
子供は親のことを信頼しないし
そういう素晴らしい時代になりましたから
家族はバラバラで 兄弟お互い同士でまるっきり信頼しないし
だから頼りにならないということになっちゃうんです
そうすると 自分が年取ってくると
あの連中は頼りにならない
ですから 自分でお墓をあちこち探して
とてもいいところで 空気のきれいなところで
富士山が見えるところで
きれいな水が滝が流れているところでお墓を作ろうと
それでやっぱりお坊さんがね
供養しなくちゃいけないんだから
それも永代供養というシステムができちゃって
まあそこを払えば永代供養するということになるんです
で 忘れているのは お寺が永代供養システムを作ったのは
それみんなのお位牌とか
なんか一箇所にドーンと放り込んで
どんなお寺でも年何回か法事があるんですよ
それは何があってもやるんです
だからその時は当然お布施を持ってきて
参加する人々のご先祖様の供養もするんです
それに合わせるだけなんです
別に 12月 33 日  13 日に亡くなった人が永代供養費お金を払っているんだから
では 12月33日 なんだらかんだら人のためにと全然やりませんよ
そういうふうには 名前を書いてお願いしておいたっていうのは
それはまあ年中やっている時は
もう全ての人々が幸福で成仏できますようにと
いっぺんにまとめてお祈りして
これ 30 分で終わる  そういうことができるんだから
お寺もやっぱり永代供養システムも作ってるんです
他人が供養して天国に行かせてくれると信じることは邪見です
他人が供養して私は大丈夫
私は息子がいるんだからね
ヒンドゥー教ではそう思うんですよ
ヒンドゥー教の人々は
自分に結婚して息子が生まれないと
ものすごく怖くなるんです
なぜかというと ヒンドゥー教では供養できるのは息子なんです
だから もし子供を男が生まれてこなかったら
まあ神に見放されて ラーマさんに神の名前が変わっちゃったんで
ヒンドゥー教で現代のインドではラーマと
今はね 昔は別な名前でしたけどね
で 見放されて離されていることになるんです
あのウパニシャッドでもヴェーダ聖典でも
そういうことはすごい心配して書いてあります
そこで他人の供養でね
自分で何もしないで 自分がいい加減で生活してて
他人の供養で天国に行けると思ったら
これが邪見なんです あ
これ上忘れちゃったね
肉体 なんで日本でこのそんなにお墓に執着するのかに
なんで富士山が見えるところでお墓を作るんでしょうかというと
これは肉体は永遠なりというね
心は完全無視 優越してるんですよ
ですから このそれが明らかに邪見です
それで邪見二つ過ぎていますよ
そうすると邪見者は確実に不幸なところに行くとお釈迦様の言葉があるんです